experts call into question the White
House models on coronavirus deaths hole
appear in the government's financial
response and Chuck Schumer and Donald
Trump go added via open letter I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let others track what you do keep
yourself safe it expressvpn dot-com /
Ben all righty so as always we begin
with our corona virus numbers update
because that's of course when everybody
needs to know right now the United
States stands in just over six thousand
deaths from corona virus yesterday was a
day in which we lost according to world
ah meters that info which is the same as
the Johns Hopkins map all these stats
are basically the same a little bit
under one thousand people yesterday and
that was a little bit fewer than the day
before the day before was like a
thousand thirty nine so hopefully we are
going to start to see this flatten out
rather than escalate although the models
suggest that this thing is going to
escalate rather wildly up until
mid-april particularly the University of
Washington model suggests that April
15th and they've navilet at April 16th
we will see upwards of two thousand two
hundred and sixty deaths in the United
States from a corona virus but it is
these models that are exactly the
question we don't know how accurate the
models are we don't know what sort of
data goes into them we're not sure
exactly why the day that the data that
comes out of them comes out of them are
they based on bad information from China
are they based on Italy are they based
on the expectation of continuation of
strong social measures are they based on
the expectation that there will be no
increase in ICU beds or ventilators
right all of this stuff is variable
they're just so many variables and these
equations and that's not the fault of
the people who do the modeling the
biggest problem here of course is that
we have to rely on models that have
extraordinary play in the joints in
order to determine whether we ought to
shut down the entire world economy for
an undetermined period of time and also
these models have yet to recommend what
exactly happens at the end of the model
so for example that University of
Washington model this is my biggest
question the University of Washington
model that everybody is citing that
model ends at approximately August so
right now that University of Washington
model that that one is suggesting that
we are going to be at about hmm
ninety-three thousand deaths by the end
of August somewhere in that neighborhood
and it ends there
like that's the end of it so that it's
not as though we know what happens after
that and that's one of the really big
questions here is how exactly do you
determine where where this ends is there
a second wave is it does the summer kill
it off it seems like everybody is sort
of not answering the really hard
questions which is where is this a year
from now two years from now if we hold
it down now are the resources such that
we actually are able to ramp up to
expect a second wave what happens when
we release everybody from their
self-contained quarantines what happens
here so right now if you look at that
model and this is the one that has been
the most cited this this health model
from the from the University of
Washington the organization is called
the Institute let's say is it's called
the Institute for I want to make sure I
get this right the the Institute for
Health metrics and evaluation the AIA
the IH m e which is an independent
population health Research Center at
University of Washington right now they
are suggesting that the peak will happen
on April 15th they say that's peak
resource use and they are suggesting
that on that day there will be two
hundred sixty three thousand beds needed
in the United States there will be a bed
shortage across the United States and
some 88 thousand beds they're suggesting
there will be some 39,000 727 ICU beds
needed on that day as opposed to about
twenty thousand available and therefore
there will be a shortage of nearly
twenty thousand beds and they say there
will be thirty 1782 ventilators needed
now those numbers you know when it
sounds you know like a very odd number
that's a sort of exactitude that no
model can actually predict right it
could be off by a hundred it could be
off by two hundred could be up by a ton
and in fact if you look at their charts
what you see is these huge ranges of
possibilities right there's a low wave
possibility there's a high range
possibility right now they are
suggesting that the number of deaths per
day like if we look at the stats their
stats have basically been I would say
close to reality so far although not
exactly on that they're constantly
readjusting their models so they had
suggested that yesterday which was April
2nd that there would be a thousand 36
deaths we saw that there were nine
hundred and sixty-eight deaths right so
they're off but how much they're off
they're off by what ten percent they're
something like that around is somewhere
between seven and
percent they're projecting that today
there will be about 1,200 deaths a
following day 1,400 deaths all the way
up to about 2,600 deaths on April 16th
which would be the peak right April 15th
April 16th that'd be the peak and then
it would start to decline they're
predicting that by June basically June
1st you'll see about 200 deaths per day
and that will go all the way down to
approximately 30 20 in at the end of
June
so the end of June is where they're
really predicting that this thing is
gonna stop they believe that even by May
1st
we are still going to be having
northwards of 1500 deaths per day but
there are serious questions as to
exactly how well these models are going
to predict things because they're really
using New York as sort of the basis for
everything they're suggesting that the
New York model that's going to be the
model for a lot of the big cities around
the country and we've actually not seen
those sorts of numbers coming out of Los
Angeles now the model does adjust for
differences in an area so if you look at
California for example the IMA tree
model suggests a lot less death in
California than in New York right they
think that because California acted
early and because it's been spreading
here slower and because we're not all on
top of each other the way people are on
New York that for example by April 26
they think the peak resource use in
California is gonna be a little delayed
by April 26 there will be 12,000 421
beds needed but there will be beds
available and there will be no bed
shortage they suggest that in California
that'll be 1866 ICU beds needed and zero
beds shortage and that there'll be a
total of fourteen hundred and ninety
three ventilators needed right that's a
big difference from New York City so
where exactly we stand at this point is
not super clear I would say the models
so far have been predictive I mean that
they have omim I'm not gonna say they're
wildly off but there's so much play in
the joints and so much that we don't
even know about the virus yet I mean
we're still finding out whether the
virus is the airborne or whether it
actually requires droplets in order to
spread so because of all of that
uncertainty this does raise the question
of how are we going to know if what we
did was successful or not in strict
statistical terms how we're gonna know
if what we did was successful because
there are countervailing concerns now
normally in a medical setting it is easy
to tell what was successful and what was
not right if somebody dies who are
unsuccessful if somebody lives then you
were successful but in terms of what if
the counter veiling
policy requires the destruction of 20
million jobs which is now economists are
suggesting then we're gonna see 20
million lost jobs by April 12th which is
about the time when the United States is
going to peak air how many deaths for
stalled and not even prevented forestall
grab because we don't know what happens
in the second wave again this model only
goes till August how many deaths
forestall is worth losing 20 million
jobs because there will be attendant
poverty and death and and depression and
mental health issues and all sorts of
problems on the other end that's not to
suggest what we're doing right now is
wrong is to suggest that we have yet to
hear any of the public health experts
actually weigh in on how many deaths are
likely to be prevented by the policy
over the course of a year right we kind
of know how many deaths might be
prevented over the course of the next
3-4 months if we do this right because
if we don't do it right then you end up
with 500,000 deaths as opposed to
100,000 deaths you end up with a million
deaths as opposed to a hundred thousand
deaths but I've yet to hear any of the
public health officials suggest that
they have any idea what's gonna come in
September and the answer is they don't
really know what's gonna come in
September they don't know whether this
thing is gonna die off in the summer
there's just too much we don't know at
this point so one of the questions
becomes when you have this level of
uncertainty what is the best policy in
case of uncertainty do you lock
everything down indefinitely and when
does indefinitely come to an end because
if you lock everything down indefinitely
then the costs are being made manifest
every single day but the benefits are
unprovable
and when I say unprovable what I mean is
that there is no way to verify how many
lives are actually being saved because
you can't see the countervailing
statistic red means doesn't exist it
exists in a counterfactual right if we
all went out we did moderate social
distancing for example all the young
people went back to everybody over the
age of 60 stay at home everybody under
the age of 60 was wearing a mask in
social distancing we don't actually know
what that looks like because it's not
happening we know what's happening now
we know what that looks like but we
don't know what would happen if we did
the other thing right this is one of the
problems with trying to project this
stuff into the future and so with all
these variables what would be nice is if
somebody from the public health
profession would suggest we have a
general idea of how many deaths are
going to be saved or prevented over the
course of the next year including with
the second wave including with people
going back out and and engaging in
moderate social distancing over the
course of the next year because you know
for sure that the levels of death are
going to lower if you lock everybody in
their house for the next three months
for the next three months they
but you just don't know what's gonna
happen after that the reason I bring all
of this up is because there are serious
questions that have to be asked right
now and especially for the next couple
of weeks I think everybody is on board
for the next two weeks probably with the
with the massive sort of lockdown that's
taking place across the country but as
time progresses as we are seeing from
Europe things get worse permanent
changes happen people lose their jobs
permanently and holes are already
appearing in the government's response
financially speaking so we're gonna have
to take a lot more seriously how we get
out of this thing what does this look
like and I need to hear from the public
health experts what that looks like it's
not just enough for them to say we're
saving lives in here now I know that's
normally your job I don't blame you that
that's normally your job but I need to
hear what exactly this looks like on the
other end if the economy tanks I need to
hear a mixture of policy prescriptions
from people who are on the economic side
and people who are on the public health
side I I'm fully with you on
prioritizing public health but I've not
even heard a metric of success yet like
what if what if the countervailing stat
is that 200,000 people would die if we
did the moderate social distancing but
120,000 people will die over the course
of the next year if we didn't do if we
if we locked everybody up then the
question becomes okay 80,000 lives lost
in order to save 20 million jobs and you
know maybe on the other end another
20,000 30,000 suicides may be people
falling into depression right these sort
of stats I'm not saying I know the stats
I don't know the stats that's the point
I'm saying that if we're so if we're
supposed to hear from the experts then
it would be nice to hear from the
experts instead we're sort of getting a
black box here in terms of all of the
countervailing concerns I'm not the only
one asking this question the Washington
Post is asking this question today and
we're gonna get to that in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that you're spending an awful lot of
time on the internet right now you're
not gonna run out of TV shows and you're
gonna not run out of time in the next
month because you can be locked up in
your house so you're gonna be using the
internet an awful lot and that means
that this is like a hackers paradise if
you're a hacker right now is like your
dream time you just get to steal
everybody's credit card number unless
they are using Express VPN expressvpn
protects your privacy and security here
is something that you might not know you
can also use Express VPN to even unlock
movies and shows that are only available
in other countries this is not
committing fraud or committing a crime
or anything it's just that if you don't
know if the excites don't know where you
are then they can't actually lock you
down
by location you could use this whole
week to use expressvpn to binge Doctor
Who on UK Netflix if you actually wanted
to it's actually pretty easy to do so
you can fire up your expressvpn app you
can change your location and then you
can watch whatever is available over
there don't do anything illegal guys
expressvpn hides your IP address lets
you control where you want sites to
think you are located if you love anime
then you can use Express VPN to access
Japanese Netflix and be spirited away
it's not just Netflix expressvpn works
with any streaming service Hulu be B see
iPlayer YouTube you name it there are
hundreds of VPNs out there the reason I
use Express VPN to watch shows is it is
indeed ridiculously fast there's never
any buffering or lag you can stream in
HD no problem expressvpn is also
compatible with all of your devices
phones media consoles Smart TVs and more
so you can watch what you want on a
personal device or on the big spring
screen wherever you are if you visit my
special link right now at Express at VPN
comm slash pen and get an extra three
months of expressvpn for free support
the show watch what you want protect
yourself with expressvpn and expressvpn
comm slash man obviously the protection
of yourselves the thing I'm most worried
about expressvpn com its lifespan so as
I say that the problem with the
modelling is that modelling is
inherently uncertain and you heard this
from dr. Fowler you heard this from dr.
Burks but if modeling is all that we
have to base our response on then the
question is going to be at what point do
the models suggest that we can go back
to work and what points of the models
suggest that the amounts of death that
are going to be prevented over the
course of the next year not the next
three months over the course of the next
year are worthy of shutting down the
entire world economy and shutting down
the American economy to the tune of tens
of millions of lost jobs and millions of
lives wrecked okay let's be frank about
this when people lose a job the
assumption is they're going to get
another job that may very well be true
but it also here it may very well be
true that if you're a small business
owner who piled all your savings into
starting a restaurant and that
restaurant just went away forever okay
that is a that is a life that has been
wrecked if you are a person who had some
savings and now you've lost your job and
the stock market has been hit and you're
forced to liquidate your stock in order
to pay your bills and the government
responds ain't coming for months that is
a life that has been wrecked and to
pretend that quality of life doesn't
matter that the only thing that matters
are these sorts of projections is wrong
again for the fourth time I'm not
calling for people to stop social
distancing I'm the one who's been
pushing hardest for social distancing
I've been calling for social distancing
since early March just like everybody
else when it became apparent that this
crisis was actually a crisis but the
I have not yet heard from the from
experts sufficient to tell me what the
metrics metrics of success looked like
if you were running a business you
wouldn't accept this sort of the this
sort of compromise if you were running a
business you wouldn't accept people
coming in and saying we can forestall
you hundreds of millions of dollars
worth of savings and you say how and
they say we don't know right we know
that we'll save you some money in the
short term but we have no idea what that
looks like six months from now
also we need you to shut down your
business for the next three months it's
gonna be very difficult for anyone to
explain based on this modeling that has
been provided so far what anything looks
like and you're hearing this from the
people who are in the epidemiology feels
right they're all speculating you hear
from some people this will be over by
June 1st you hear from some people this
will be over by May 1st
and maybe this is me railing against the
sky because nobody actually has the data
maybe this is we just have to take our
best guess and wing it and again I'm
willing to do that for a set period of
time I am not willing to do that
indefinitely and I don't think anyone is
willing to do that indefinitely I do not
think that anyone is willing to lock
themselves in their house until June 1st
based on models that do not even tell us
what happens after August 1st again the
IMA HD model can be completely right and
it still tells us nothing about what
happened September 1 which I find that
hard to believe but it is true right
where are the second wave models maybe
again we don't have information about
what happens after that what happens
when there is no herd immunity and there
is no vaccine there's just not enough
information out there which is why every
day the people are looking for a vaccine
becomes more and more vital because
bottom line is without any sort of
mitigating effects without any sort of
drugs that can mitigate the effects of
this without a buildup and ICU capacity
or ventilator capacity what exactly are
we gaining here right this is this is
the point that I've been making all
along all we are doing is buying time
for you not to get the virus we're not
buying time for you do never get the
virus we are buying time for you to not
get the virus so the question is what
happens on the other side when you do
get the virus because the chances are
very strong then the fall everybody is
gonna get the virus because we're gonna
be out and about and doing the things
that we like to do and even with the
masks the chances are pretty strong that
I just can't imagine the American people
walking around in October 7 months from
now wearing masks in public I just don't
think that the United States is not
built for that it's not the same thing
as other cultures that may be for good
and it may be for bad and I'm not the
only person asking this question the
Washington Post has a piece today that
says experts in
Advisers now white houses 240,000
coronavirus deaths estimate according to
William Juan Josh now see Ashley Parker
and Joe Achenbach leading disease
forecasters whose research the White
House used to conclude a hundred
thousand to two hundred forty thousand
people will die nationwide from the
corona virus were mystified when they
saw the administration's projection this
week the experts said they don't
challenge the numbers validity but they
have no idea how the White House arrived
at them I'm confused how do you not
challenge the validity but your but you
have no idea how they arrived at them
that's basically the same we don't know
what the hell anybody's talking about
White House officials have refused to
explain how they generated the figure
they have not provided the underlying
data so others can assess its
reliability or provided long term
strategies to lower the death count some
of president Trump's advisors have
expressed doubts about the estimate
according to three White House officials
who spoke on the condition of anonymity
there have been fierce debates inside
the White House about its accuracy at a
taskforce meeting this week Anthony foul
a told others there are too many
variables at play in the pandemic to
make the models reliable he said I've
looked at all the models I spent a lot
of time on the models they don't tell
you anything you can't really rely upon
models then what the hell are we talking
about I mean seriously you may as well
just say we have no idea how many people
are gonna die we think it's a lot shut
down the entire economy and the reason
they're not doing this the reason
they're not doing this is because they
want you to rely on the quote-unquote
experts now I'm fine with relying on
people who know more about epidemiology
than Idol I'm not challenging the inputs
on the models I'm not even challenging
the models themselves I'm saying the
people who make the models are
challenging the models I'm saying the
people who are who are creating the
models understand that there's play in
the joints if you can't really rely upon
the models then again just a question
how are you creating a metric of success
what's the metric of success and the
metric of success cannot be you know
Governor Andrew Cuomo going out there
and saying things like the metric of
successes have we saved one life okay
that's just ridiculous that's not a
public policy proposal lots of things
would save one life you know banning
cars would save one life no one's
talking about doing that
keeping everybody home will certainly
save some lives the question is for how
long who the people are who are going to
get it does it buy as time to increase
capacity is that time going to be useful
right none of these questions have
really been asked Robert Redfield least
a director for the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention prevention and
the VP's office have all similarly
voiced doubts about the projections
accuracy Jeffrey shamon a Columbia
University epidemia
whose models were cited by the White
House said his own work on the pandemic
doesn't go far enough into the future to
make predictions akin to the White House
fatality forecast so the models are only
for the next few months he says we don't
have a sense of what's going on in the
era now we don't know what people will
do in the future we don't know if the
virus is seasonal the estimate
apparently was a rushed affair according
to mark lips hitch a leading
epidemiologist and director for the
Harvard University Center for
communicable disease dynamics
he said they contacted us on Tuesday
they asked for answers in feedback by
Thursday so they give us 24 hours and so
we have a number other experts noted the
White House didn't even explain the time
period the death estimate supposedly
captures is that just a few months or
the year plus it will take to deploy a
vaccine everything was presented on
basically a single slide among
epidemiologist the estimates raised more
questions than an answer not just about
methodology and accuracy but also about
purpose the primary goal of such models
usually is to allow authorities to game
out scenarios for see challenges create
coherent long-term strategy Shemin said
I wish there were more of a concerted
national plan I wish it had started a
month and a half ago maybe two months
ago Natalie Dean about by the way worth
noting back as of mid-february doctor
foul Qi was out there publicly saying
that he didn't think that the risk of
mass infection in the United States was
high Natalie Dean a biostatistical on a
virus vaccine evaluation with the w-h-o
says the whole reason you create models
is to help you make decisions but you
have to actually act on those
projections and answers otherwise the
models are useless yes but we are acting
and we still don't know what the hell's
in the models I mean we have no idea
what exactly these models look like
Debra Burke said the projection was
based on five or six modelers including
from Imperial College in Britain Harvard
Columbia in northeastern universities
but two models appeared to have been
particularly influential one was the
Imperial College model that we've talked
about before which now suggests south of
20,000 deaths in the UK thanks to strict
social distancing and even that it's
unclear from that model do they mean
like social distancing and staying at
home for a year because then it's not
20,000 then it's higher than 20,000 in
the United States the one that we've
been using is that I am a Qi model that
I was talking about
apparently burke said that her task
force initially reviewed the work of 12
models then we went back to the drawing
board for a week or two and worked from
the ground up utilizing actual reporting
of cases it's the way we built HIV
models he be models malaria models when
we finished the other group that was
working in parallel which we didn't know
about the IMA chi model gave its own
estimate they initially estimated deaths
throughout this
total 38,000 to 162,000 which is a lower
projection than many others and actually
beneath the White House's own estimate
but because of the lower figures experts
believe it was a main source for the
White House's best-case scenario of a
hundred thousand to two hundred and
forty thousand death meanwhile the White
House was appearing to rely on Imperial
College first worst-case scenario which
estimated as as many as 2.2 million US
deaths if no action were taken 1.1
million deaths if moderate mitigation
strategies were adopted and an
unspecified number if drastic measures
were taken well unspecified number would
be the big question right now like that
is the big question is it not again we
don't know the time period we do know
that the IMA chi models assumes that
every single state is going to impose
stay at home orders some states
including Alabama and Missouri have not
done that yet it also assumes the entire
country will maintain the restrictions
until summer Trump has extended the
White House's restrictions until April
30th he's made clear he wants to open
this as soon as possible also nobody
knows exactly how far this extends again
the Washington Post making the same
point that I'm making you can look at
the animation models yourself they're
online you can see how far they extend
the answer is August if the White
House's projection covers only the next
few months
like the IMA chi model does the true
death toll will miss will almost
certainly be larger because the US will
probably see additional waves of cove in
nineteen until a vaccine is deployed the
IMA chi was not based on what is usually
called the susceptible infectious
recovered model which is a mathematical
way to represent three different
populations in an outbreak people
vulnerable to infection people who are
infectious and people who are gradually
removed either by death or recovery but
the IMA chi took a different model it's
a statistical model that takes the
trending curves of death from china for
example and fits that curve to emerging
death data from cities and counties to
predict what comes next it's a valuable
tool but it's inherently optimistic
because it assumes all states responded
swiftly as china says says a
biostatistical estate group Christopher
Murray said his model was created for a
different purpose from Imperial College
he said we created our model to help
hospitals plan how many beds they would
need the purpose of imperials model is
to make people realize that government
intervention is crucial and what would
happen without that okay so bottom line
is nobody knows a damn thing I mean
really like we know things are bad we
know things will be worse if we if we
leave our houses for the next three
months that's it that's all we know I've
said all the things we know we don't
know what happens after that we don't
know what happens when you go back to
we don't know if there's a second wave
we don't know if the summer kills this
thing off we don't know what the
infection rate is that's still variable
we don't know what the fatality case
fatality rate is that is still variable
we don't know anything okay so the
question is going to be when do we know
enough to say people have to start
getting back to work when do we start to
say that the least vulnerable members of
our population should be going to work
right now with the social distancing and
and with the masks when do we know all
of this because there are real-time
costs being incurred right now in the
name just money
they're real-time costs being incurred
right now and I'd love to hear the
public health experts explain a more
wholesome view of what exactly success
looks like I understand what success
looks like in the first wave I'm with
you that's why I'm not saying get out
and do things right now I understand
what success looks like
stay home follow the orders give this a
chance to work but I want to know what
the second wave looks like because if
they are predicting that everybody is
gonna get this by the end of the year
basically and they're not predict and
they're not making that prediction
available to the public because they
know that if they tell us we're all
gonna get infected by the end of the
year we're gonna go out right now and if
in fact there is such a thing as herd
immunity and if in fact what we're doing
is lowering the curve but not lowering
the number of deaths over time because
for example we actually don't have ICU
capacity your ventilator capacity and
we're not gonna ramp those up strongly
enough then we have to consider what
exactly are the classroom awards of
particular policies what happens if we
all go back if we start going back to
work not all go back to her what happens
if we start going back to work May 1st
what happens if we start going back to
work soon first what happens if we start
going back to work July 1st what if
there is no work July 1st one of it what
if we're out there and what if what if
you start seeing riots and breakdowns
like we're starting to see in Europe
right now these are actual concerns
people we're living in a real time real
world scenario this is not all modeling
in labs so what would be great is if we
could see some epidemiologist discuss
you know like a realistic scenario we'll
were not locked in our houses for the
next year and where time doesn't end on
August 1st I would like to know these
things because one of two things is true
either the deaths end August 1st in
which case we're doing all the right
things here we're locking it down
everything's great or the deaths do not
end on August 1st and there is a massive
second wave in which case what are we
doing now and also there's the third
case
area where we've locked it down to the
point where there's a mild wave a
segment but have you heard anything
about a second wave have you heard
anything about what happens when I go
back to work have you heard anything
about what happens when you reopen the
economy have you heard anything about
the cost of this thing epidemiologist
are gonna need you better as time goes
on people are gonna demand answers and
they deserve those answers we're gonna
get some more of this in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that
government is using its power to do
basically whatever it wants right now
and the fact is that sometimes that is
justified but there are certain areas
where it is completely unjustified we've
seen people with tyrannical instincts
doing ridiculous things in certain areas
of the country in LA the LA County
Sheriff actually tried to shut down all
gun shops in the county calling them
non-essential businesses at a time when
they were releasing criminals from jail
literally releasing criminals from jail
okay well this might be a reason why you
should have a weapon okay one of the
reasons why you have a gun is to protect
yourself to protect your family to
protect your property from the
predations of others and sometimes the
government wants to stop you from doing
that now would be an excellent time to
shop at Bravo company manufacturing they
build a professional-grade product which
is built to combat standards that's
because BCM believes the same level of
protection should be provided to every
American regardless if they're a private
citizen or a professional the people at
BCM assume that when a rifle leaves
their shop it will be used in a
life-or-death situation
by a responsible citizen law enforcement
officer or a soldier oversees every
component of a BCM rifle is hand
assembled and tested to a life-saving
standard the people at BCM feel it is
their moral responsibility as Americans
to provide tools that will not fail when
it's not just a paper target VCM works
with leading in structures of
marksmanship from top levels of
America's Special Ops forces from Marine
Corps Fortran force reconnaissance to US
special army operations forces teaching
you the skills necessary to defend
yourself your family or others I own
firearms because I want to protect my
own property and because I have a right
to do so and because they're bad people
out there and I'm not gonna rely on the
government to save me from those bad
people not when they're letting people
out of prison learn more about Bravo
company manufacturing head on over to
Bravo Company MFG comm you can discover
more about their product special offers
upcoming news that is Bravo Company MFG
comm you should check out their awesome
videos meet the people who make their
products at youtube.com slash up Bravo
Company
USA and that's youtube.com slash Bravo
company USA ok so going back to those
models and I'm not talking at the
talk about the actual statistics now
let's look at the actual statistics
country by country so right now the
industrialized countries that are
obviously having the hardest time our
countries like Spain and in Italy right
Spain and Italy are just having a brutal
time of it if you'll get the statistics
yesterday Italy had 961 deaths and
almost as many deaths as the United
States the total population of Spain is
46 points point seven million as opposed
to the United States they about it about
as many deaths as we did but they have
let's see 36 divided by four they've 99
times fewer people than we do so that's
is so they're getting just shellacked
Italy had 760 deaths yesterday which
actually is the beginning of their down
curve we can we can absolutely help
France got walloped yesterday friends
had thirteen hundred and fifty-five
deaths the real question is deaths per 1
million population that's a statistic
that is constantly rising the United
States right now has 18 deaths per
million population Italy and Spain have
well over 200 right there like 230 for
Italy and 221 for Spain and they're
further along in their curve than we are
until you'd expect the United States to
rise so the question is gonna be what
those stats actually look like if we
took that as the model so what let's
assume that when those stats are done
that you end up in the neighborhood of
300 deaths per million for Italy or
Spain right 300 deaths per million so
that's when you end up with like 90,000
deaths in the United States right if
that if we ever on the same model and we
ends up with 300 deaths per million of
the population in Italy or in Spain and
we are on the same curve then we would
be looking at 300 deaths per million so
three so 300 times
330 and you end up with ninety nine
thousand deaths it's what a hundred
thousand deaths if we are not Italy or
Spain if we contain this better than
Italy and Spain and if Italy and Spain
don't experience the second wave and
it's too early to determine whether they
will experience the second wave when
they let people out of lockdown then we
are not going to end up with anywhere
near those kinds of deaths right if we
end up in the neighborhood of a vey
France which right now has 83 and maybe
ends up at a hundred or 120 deaths per
million population then you're looking
at one third of that right so all of
this depends on what we do now which is
why we should lock down for now but
again we need to know where this is
going in the future because the costs
that are being incurred in real time
our grave they are serious and people
who are taking them lately and
suggesting that you can't even ask
questions like this because otherwise
you're undermining the credibility of
the program like I don't know what world
they are living in people are losing
their livelihoods people are being
forced to go to food banks we're going
to have an unemployment rate that is
higher than the Great Depression here I
mean the Great Depression
lest we forget was the shaping event for
an entire generation of Americans my
grandparents were shaped by the Great
Depression they lived the rest of their
lives in the shadow of the Great
Depression this is what happens when
major events occur this is the biggest
event any of us have ever seen in our
lifetime and it is not particularly
close I was there for 9/11 this Dwarfs
9/11 in terms of the size and impact on
the American population and right 9/11
was an attack on America and then we
took measures to protect ourselves and
those measures at the time were
considered extraordinarily restrictive
right we had FISA warrants and we had
data gathering when we had some new
surveillance electronically and we had
the TSA patting us down and I remember
all the controversy over these things oh
my god the TSA is patting us down now
imagine a world where the government had
said you're going to stay in your house
for the next three months okay
yeah that's what we have right now so to
pretend that we can't take into account
the costs of this of this program it's
ridiculous we ought to be taking into
account the cost of the program I'm not
pretending I know the answers but the
problem is I'm not sure anybody else
knows the answers either and I want to
hear some honest accounting from the
people in power in the Trump
administration in the epidemiological
models I want to hear what they have to
say I keep hitting the same point here
we don't have enough data and some
people are saying that's an excuse for
us never to take any action but to stay
at home what I'm saying is when the
costs are being racked up in real time
you better damn well come up with the
data fast when people are just gonna
start ignoring you seriously like either
the estimates roll in and they happen to
be particularly accurate and there are
new estimates made as to what happens
after we all go back to work or people
are just gonna go back to work because
that is the way that human beings
operate right right now according to
Reuters the economic crisis spawned by
the corona virus pandemic has produced a
wave of grim us data with likely more to
come as millions lose jobs businesses
shudder and spending stops at some point
the bottom will be reached given how
fast the situation has developed judging
when that happens in real time will
prove challenging for economists who
usually depend on monthly quarterly or
yearly trends and data to judge the
state of the business cycle the corona
virus outbreak is not a business cycle
event perhaps
to once-in-a-century health crisis where
normal choices about where to go and
what to spend are influenced by a
combination of fear and government edict
but it's unclear exactly how bad this is
going to get apparently the estimates
are now suggesting that we are going to
end up with like 20 million lost jobs by
April 12th okay in a second we are going
to get to the White House
recommendations where we go from here
and again it seems like everybody is
focused on like what we do today and
that's fine we should focus on what we
do today I've been giving advice to
people on what to do today I've been
very stringently recommending that
everybody follow the law and not only
follow the law but take extra measures
right I've been recommending masks since
probably a week ago
right a week and a half ago but they had
honest to god they had better start
setting some actual estimates as to how
many people are going to die a year out
before we have the vaccine developed if
we stay in if we do not stay in we need
to start making some some serious
data-driven choices here not simply
things are bad stay home that's not
going to be enough not when you are
looking at in Europe they're looking to
break a part of the EU like you may not
like the EU that's fine but that is a
pretty massive change they're talking
about the entire European Union
splitting right now why because every
country is now shutting its borders
they're talking about total government
control of economies in Europe there's
massive rioting in southern Italy right
now because supply chains have been
broken and because the government has
locked everything down this is not
sustainable it is not sustainable
everyone knows it's not sustainable by
the way ask pouchy ask births everyone
knows this is unsustainable
the only question is how long we can
sustain it and the other question is how
long we should sustain it and nobody has
yet said how long we should sustain it
if you ask
public health experts when do we get to
go back to work they will and I've asked
met you if you've listened to my radio
show I've asked like two a day for the
last three weeks basically when do we
all get to go back to work some people
will say May first what does that look
like well we don't know we'll transfer
it out when we all get to go back to our
car they're gonna be ballgames in
September they're gonna be ballgames in
August what happens with the second way
we have no idea
okay operating on the basis of
incomplete data with real-time costs
that is a thing we are doing right now
and let's not pretend they're not
real-time costs or that it's bad to
recommend the real-time cause okay in
just a second we're gonna get to what
the what the White House is recommending
at this time and we're going to talk
about the
a couple of just botched media hits I
mean really botched media hits on the
Trump administration I'll get to all of
that in a second by the way one of the
reasons that I'm you know sounding the
alarm with regards to the economy is
because despite all the talk of the
government response being just wonderful
and tremendous there's a report out
today that some people could wait 20
weeks to receive checks 20 weeks until
August we've been told the model doesn't
even extend past August so if you're if
you're not if you don't of a check
coming until August how the hell do you
expect people are gonna survive you
think people are just gonna set home and
not go to a job that they've been
furloughed from that they are not going
to go back and reopen their business
when there's no check in the mail is
that what you expect here the small
business lending program is chaos nobody
knows exactly what the standards are
banks are not lending same-day they're
not I'm talking to small business owners
they were told by the administration by
Congress that this thing was gonna be
open and ready to go it is not open it
is not ready to go okay as government
proves itself incompetent on virtually
every level except punishing you when
you go outside there's going to be a lot
of blowback from this again we can stick
good for people for paying attention to
the orders right now
do I think that this is gonna maintain
till May with no money in the mail and
the food banks running out of food and
nobody having the money to give enough
charity to sustain the food banks as the
government forcibly shuts down an entire
economy I do not think that is the case
something is gonna have to change we're
gonna get some more of this in just one
second first you ought to head over
right now to daily wire.com why well it
is that glorious time of the week when I
give a shout out to a daily wire
subscriber today it is Atlas dynamics on
Instagram who appreciates perfection
when they see it and sets the record
straight on Norway in this picture Atlas
has the world's greatest beverage vessel
sitting next to their computer
displaying the blueprints of what
appears to be a nice design they're
working on the post caption the post
caption reads can't deny the awesomeness
of this legendary tumblr enjoying home
school office of my brand spanking new
ultimate drinking vessel and working
through my exam day by day thank you so
much real Daily wire and official Ben
Shapiro for keeping my day awesome in
not socialist in Norway hashtag at
legendary coffee hashtag never socialist
hashtag leftist here's hashtag home
office hashtag leftist here's tumblr
awesome hopefully Bernie Sanders is
watching and we'll take note while he's
doing his pooping also if you've not yet
had a chance to see some of our new
content called all-access live you
should head over to daily wire to
comment check it out Jeremy boring and I
kicked it off a few weeks ago all of our
other hosts of Doug
livestreams over at daly wire.com will
continue all this week at 8 p.m. Eastern
5 p.m. Pacific all access live it's a
lot more relaxed than our normal
programming it's less focused on
bringing you news and information more
about hanging out with you at the end of
a long day since we're all isolated
anyway
the show's intended for all access
members long term but for now we're
opening up to all of our members because
you're part of the community please let
us know what you think of it if you're
around at 8 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m.
Pacific tonight join us on the
all-access live show over at Daley
wire.com you're listening to the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
now when I say that this is
unsustainable one of the reasons is
unsustainable is because the experts
have to actually be experts in order for
the experts to have legitimacy for us to
take their expertise seriously is that
fair and if the experts don't know all
that much it's very difficult to take
all the experts super seriously and I
understand information is variable and
it arrives in real time I'm not saying
don't pay attention to the experts I'm
saying we need better information from
the experts five seconds ago they were
telling us that masks don't work now dr.
oz is on TV telling us that we oughta
wear masks over our face not just like
n95 masks which are unavailable
generally not just surgical masks which
at least prevent you from breathing out
he's telling you should wear bandanas if
five seconds ago
they were telling us that it is a waste
of time for you to actually wear like a
full-on and 95 face mask to the grocery
store and now they're telling us by the
way slap a bandanna over your face and
maybe that'll protect you do you feel
protective fewer and control really
here's dr. oz explaining that we should
wear bandanas
well scarfs not gonna be as good as a
surgical mask and that won't be as good
as a n95 mask but there's a rethinking
around masks in part because we've
realized that the virus doesn't go deep
in your lungs
it probably inserts this up right at the
very tip of your nose and it's imagine
little doors there which are where the
cells connects receptors can accept the
virus the virus is a key and it unlocks
those doors and goes in older people
have more of those doors than younger
people that's why they get more of the
infection we believe and wearing any
kind of facial covering could drop could
block the larger droplets from getting
into your nose so net-net it's better
than nothing but not a ton better than
nothing okay it's better than nothing
but not a ton better than nothing great
I feel I feel much safer now meanwhile
dr. Fowey is on TV he's saying all the
states should have stay at home order
again that's fine as I say like I'm all
on board with let's get this thing
locked down but could you give us like
an expectation of when we are not going
to be locked down you know an
expectation that's realistic well we're
not all locked in our house is till
August waiting on checks that are not
going to arrive from debt that we cannot
actually sell how about that and like
Abbott's something realistic here that'd
be good here's a factory saying all
states should have stay at home orders
its his next quote that that really is
sort of disturbing here is vouching some
states are still not issuing stay at
home orders I mean whether there should
be a federally mandated directive for
that or not
I guess there's more of a political
question but just scientifically doesn't
everybody have to be on the same page
with this stuff yeah I think so Anderson
I don't understand why that's not
happening as you said you know the
tension between federally-mandated
versus states rights to do what they
want is something I don't want to get
into but if you look at what's going on
in this country I just don't understand
why we're not doing that okay totally
agree again I agree with him that we
should lock everything down right now I
mean you can't look at the images coming
out of New York and the stories coming
out of New York and not freaked out and
we should be freaked out but the but
here is not a but that suggests don't
pay attention to it to what the experts
are saying on what you do right now how
about like in the future here's dr.
Fauci again he's an epidemiologist right
his job is to stop disease I understand
that's his job his job is not to heal
the economy but here was foul Qi being
asked about the job losses and here was
his answer I mean I know it's difficult
but we're having a lot of suffering a
lot of death this is inconvenient from
an economic and a personal standpoint
but we just have to do it that is our
major weapon against this virus right
now we don't have a vaccine that's
deployables only thing we have it's
inconvenient okay it's a little more
than inconvenient if you lose your
business and you lose your job well I
got it can we at least not dismiss the
concerns of people who are losing their
entire livelihoods and are going to food
banks for the first time in their lives
and we hope we'll the only time in their
lives can we at least not dismiss that
and can we hear somebody why will no one
in the media ask I swear to God no one
in the media will ask simple questions
of the epidemiologist like what happens
in a second wave have you even gamed for
this how many deaths are going to be
prevented in the second wave are we
wrapping up our ICU and ventilator
capacity such that when there is a
second wave in the fall which literally
everybody expects because we're seeing
it in Asia when that happens do you
expect that there will be a number of
deaths prevented how many deaths will
actually be prevented not over the
course of the next three months which
you've modeled and I get and I agree
with over the course of the next year
because that's what we're talking about
in swell vaccine is developed right that
is the actual stop point once a vaccine
is developed that's as good as it's
gonna get there is no better than it
gets at that point they're saying that's
12 to 18 months so the question is what
happens between August of this you
in August of next year right cuz they're
talking 12 to 18 months let's take the
longer end of that let's say it takes 18
months to fully develop test and
distribute a vaccine so you're talking
about from March is which is when this
started - September of next year so
don't give me models only that stopped
at August I want to know what happens
after that
and I want to know how many lives are
saved by all of us staying home and
wrecking the economy over the course of
18 months not over the course of three
months I get over the course of three
months I'm with you over the course of
three months okay again the information
that's coming out even from people I
trust and like is so vague and
conflicting so dr. Burks she says lots
of people are asymptomatic and so we
have to follow the guidelines okay and
they're gonna be asymptomatic when we
all go back to work also right like then
they're not gonna stop being a sent in a
symptomatic what's the plan guys what's
the plan we all believe that there's a
greater proportion of people who are
asymptomatic than recognized and again
that may correspond with age with
greater number of asymptomatic cases in
people under 40
and so both severity of disease
increases in it with age but
asymptomatic potential may also decrease
with age so that it's more in the
younger age groups and so we believe
that there could be significant
transmission from asymptomatic
individuals that all of that's true and
it's gonna remain true when we all go
back to work presumably I'll tell you
what's unsustainable and some of these
recommendations the New Jersey Governor
Murphy he came out yesterday he
suggested that you're supposed to
socially distance inside your own house
like I'm sorry that that's not only is
that not sustainable that's not anything
anyone is going to do now okay so I'm
going to happen now I have three
children what the hell am I supposed to
do with them I supposed to take my month
old baby shove her in the other room go
sorry kid I'm social distancing right
now am I supposed to take my my
six-year-old who came down with the flu
and be like you know I'm gonna be over
here you take care of yourself here's a
barf bucket and some Tylenol enjoy you
can't what are you even talking about
this is not this is not realistic advice
you can't socially distance from people
who are in your own house what do know
the answer is no there's gonna come on
key a point where human beings just say
no and I'm willing to put that point off
as far as possible if you show me
what the models say about how many
deaths we are preventing one year from
now not three months from now not four
months from now not six months from now
a year from now I'm willing to do it now
while you develop those models just tell
me you're developing the freakin models
just tell me that you're gonna know
sometime in the future how many lives
were saving here because the costs are
happening now the costs are happening
right now in real time and we all know
this and anybody who just says don't
worry about tomorrow is not worrying
about the people who are suffering now
I'm worried about the people who are
dying now and I'm worried about the
people who are losing their jobs now and
losing their businesses now and losing
their livelihoods and watching their
dreams destroyed right now I'm worried
about all of those people we should all
be worried about all of those people by
the way all of those people are still
going to work okay let's just be real
about this there are a lot of people out
there like for people who pretend that
the that everybody has the luxury of
staying home during this thing they
don't there are a lot of people
particularly people who are working
low-wage jobs right the people who the
left says that people on the right don't
care about those people are still going
toward because they do not have a choice
are they supposed to stay home and
receive no check from the government
until August is that the plan let me
show you a picture there's a picture
yesterday from New York okay New York is
the epicenter of this thing okay so this
was this was put out yesterday this
tweet by a charlie okay this is put out
by ABC 7 New York quote this is the
number two train at about 6:00 p.m.
Thursday evening in a photo provided to
Eyewitness News by progressives action
Twitter account the MTA says it's
running as many trends as it can
but has been hobbled because of crews
that are out sick or sick or quarantine
public health officials who said social
distancing is the key to slowing the
spread of the deadly Kovach 19 New York
remains the hardest hit place in the
nation this is the number to number 2
train
April 2nd 6 p.m. um that ain't social
distancing gang that is mostly young
minority people who I assume are coming
back from their jobs at 6 p.m. who are
working I assume we're going to their
jobs because they don't have the luxury
of being members of the media who get to
sit at home and broadcast these are
people who have to work jobs like we're
just not being realistic about any of
this stuff we're not
I want the social distancing as much as
you I want this over as fast as possible
I want everybody to lock down as fast as
possible so it is over as fast as
possible all I want you to tell me is
that it will be over when it's over and
no one can tell me it's gonna be over
when it's over
nobody and your again we're seeing real
time real time cost to this in Europe
the entire European Union may break
apart over this thing now you may not
like the European Union but that's a
pretty major thing is it not that's a
pretty significant countervailing
concern is it not meanwhile the media is
doing yeoman's work in misinforming
people so the New York Times has a piece
today titled the 1,000 bed comfort was
supposed to aid in New York it has 20
patients it's a joke sat atop hospital
executive whose facilities are packed
with coronavirus patients um note tune
to media the comfort was never supposed
to house people with coronavirus why
because well let's see what happens when
you have a ship let's call it a time in
princess cruise ship and you put people
with coronavirus on a contained area
within a ship what what happens on that
on that cruise ship well it turns out
everybody gets coronavirus you idiots
the entire thing was designed to provide
additional hospital beds not ICU beds
not coronavirus beds who's designed to
increase the number of hospital beds
available do you think the hotels in New
York are being made over for icy use and
for ventilators it's not what's
happening nonetheless the New York Times
reports Michael Schwartz reporting such
were the expectations for the Navy
hospital ship USNS comfort and when it
chugged into New York Harbor this week
throngs of people momentarily forgetting
the structures of social distancing
crammed together along Manhattan's West
Side to catch a glimpse on Thursday the
huge white vessel which officials had
promised would bring succor to a city on
the brink sent mostly empty infuriating
executives at local hospitals the ship's
1,000 beds are largely unused it's 1,200
member crew mostly idle only 20 patients
had been transferred to the ship if I'm
blunt about it it's a joke said Michael
Dowling the head of northwell health New
York's largest hospital system everyone
can say thank you for putting up these
wonderful places and opening up these
cavernous halls but we're in a crisis
here or on a battlefield
okay well the Javits Center is open the
Samaritan's Purse hospital in Central
Park is open and so is the USS mercy and
it wasn't meant for people with
coronavirus that's not what it was
designed to do so excellent media
coverage there also in other excellent
media coverage the media are going nuts
over this story of a commander of an
aircraft carrier who was removed for a
poor judgment because he publicly
suggested that the entire aircraft
carrier should be taken out of
commission the the commanding officer
was indicted captain Bret Crozier
he was relieved of command by carrier
Strike Group commander
Admiral Stewart Baker this was announced
during a Pentagon press briefing why
because he showed poor judgment because
he warned he wrote a public memo warning
Navy leadership the decisive action was
needed to save the lives of the ship's
crew he suggested that crow CO was not
removed because of any evidence
suggesting he leaked the memo to the
press but rather for allowing the
complexity of his challenge with the
kovat break out on the ship to overwhelm
his ability to act professionally when
acting professionally was what was
needed most of the time he says that
this is the the spokesperson for the
Pentagon I have no information nor am I
trying to suggest he leaks the
information it was published in the San
Francisco Chronicle it all came as a big
surprise to all of us that it was in the
paper that's not and that's the first
time I had seen it there was a memo that
was written by crows EA earlier this
week to the Navy's Pacific Fleet mod Lee
called Crow Z has known a blast out
email to everyone he knows okay so the
guy wasn't fired for saying that bad
things are happening on the ship and we
need to do something about it he was
fired because he broke chain of command
by emailing apparently quote everyone he
knows saying that a full on battle
carrier should be taken out of
commission if you think the military
should be allowing its commanding
officers to blast out full-on emails to
everyone they know about taking one 11th
of America's chief naval capacity off
the table
I've spoken to military officers I don't
know how many military officers are in
favor of commanding officers blasting
out emails suggesting the aircraft
carriers be taken out of commission the
email said we're not at war sailors do
not need to die if we do not act now we
are failing to properly take care of our
most trusted asset our sailors mildly
said crow Zia was relieved because he
went outside the chain of command and
sent his memo over an unsecured system
adding to the chances it could be leaked
of course top Democrats slammed the move
in a statement on Thursday they said
this is a destabilizing move that will
put our servicemembers at greater risk
oh really more to stabilizing than
taking an entire battle carrier out of
out of commission well-done media for
for completely ignoring how militaries
are supposed to work Wow
so it is it is chaotic out there we need
answers as fast as possible from the
epidemiologists let's listen to the
experts guys and experts do better give
us some more information tell us how
this is going to go okay time for a
thing I like and then we'll get to a
thing that I hate so things that I like
so like all the rest of you I'm trapped
in my house with my children and this
means that it is time to watch some
children's movies all limits on screens
have been banished and so further notice
not totally true I'm trying to keep my
kid screen time limited but it is not
going successful in any case one of the
movies that I have introduced my
children to and they just love is the
Lego Batman movies so if you are a
Batman fan as I am then you'll recognize
that the Lego Batman movie is indeed
hilarious the entire thing is basically
sending up Batman
and it's Will Arnett plays Batman in
this and it is it's very clever it's
very funny and it is worthy of the watch
so here is a little bit of the trailer
for Lego Batman again keep your kids
entertained today
I can only look you in the ice right now
is my greatest enemy and I'd say that I
don't currently have a bad guy I am
fighting a few different people I like
to fight around it's really funny and
really most of the jokes are written for
adults so it's entertaining see this is
the challenge when you have kids at home
you have to watch movies that you can
handle right then they're not going to
drive you completely up a wall while
you're watching them with your kids and
this is one of those moves in Lego
Batman will be worthy of worthy of the
watch okay time for a quick thing that I
hate all righty so the there was a big
fight that broke out between President
Trump and Chuck Schumer yesterday
President Trump was railing against what
he calls a partisan witch hunt Democrats
are already looking to investigate the
Trump administration for their response
to coronavirus because it's not like
we're in the middle of the thing right
now and trying to scramble to get this
thing together what we really need is a
is a partisan attack on the
administration without looking back you
know as I did yesterday on the program
at length the last 15 20 years of the
shortages and the inability to to
develop ventilators and develop mass
capacity and the failures at every level
inside the government to develop any
sort of models that actually worked here
and the failures of the CDC and the FDA
know it was gonna be all about Trump so
yesterday President Trump went off on
the partisan investigations he is not
wrong about this he is correct about
this now is not the time to be
announcing partisan investigations and
by the way when an investigation is done
as I say unless it looks a lot like the
9/11 Commission which basically say
which basically says government sucks at
everything and they sucked here do then
it's not being honest anyway here is
Trump going off on the on the Democrats
for for politicizing this stuff right
now
I want to remind everyone here in our
nation's capitol especially in Congress
that this is not the time for politics
endless partisan investigations here we
go again have already done an
extraordinary damage to our country in
recent years you see what happens it's
witch hunt after witch hunt after witch
hunt and in the end the people doing the
witch hunt have been losing and they've
been losing by a lot and it's not any
time for witch hunts it's time to get
this enemy defeated okay he is correct
about all of this that did not stop
chuck schumer from issuing an open
letter to President Trump yesterday said
dear mr. president as the corona virus
spreads rapidly into every corner of our
nation and it's terrible grim toll grows
more severe with each passing day the
tardiness and inadequacy of this
administration's response to the crisis
becomes more painfully evident this is
not a letter designed to get anything
done it's an open letter right it was
released like I have a I'm looking at it
right now well documented shortages of
protective equipment tests medical
supplies are now beyond acute in my home
state of New York and other hard-hit
areas and similar shortages are expected
soon in many other parts of the country
while companies that volunteer to
produce ventilators and PPE are to be
commended and are appreciated America
cannot rely on a patchwork of
uncoordinated voluntary efforts to
combat the awful magnitude of this
pandemic it's long past time for your
administration to designate a senior
military official to fix this urgent
problem that officer should be given the
full authority under the defense
production act the existing federal
leadership void has left America with an
ugly spectacle in which states and
cities are literally fending for
themselves often in conflict and
competition with each other when trying
to procure precious medical supplies and
equipment the only way we will fix our
PPE and ventilator shortage is with the
data-driven organized robust plan from
the federal government anything short of
that will inevitably mean the problem
will remain unsolved and prolonging this
crisis again this is Chuck Schumer
writing an open letter to trump that is
designed for partisan political purposes
obviously as it stands today you've
charged dr. Peter Navarro an academic
economist to be leader of this effort
with all due respect dr. Navarro whose
expertise is in other areas is woefully
unqualified for this task the existence
of a separate shadow effort elsewhere in
the White House has made the
administration's response even more
confused and uncoordinated as you know
there are many logistics professionals
in the United States military it must be
pointed out that while you continue to
dismiss the defense production act as
not being needed it is clear the
of American interests has not yet been
fully harnessed either in prioritizing
and allocating urgently needed medical
supplies and equipment and rapidly
expanding domestic manufacturing efforts
to produce them or in providing
certainty to manufacturers through
purchase orders purchase guarantees or
other mechanisms that the US will use
and distribute all of the medical
equipment and supplies that they can
produce it's a matter of the utmost
urgency for the health of every American
regrettably our national response is far
behind where it should be but by acting
now there's still time to help protect
our medical professionals reduce
suffering and save lives sincerely
Charles Schumer yes I'm sure it's very
sincere so president Trump gets this
letter and and he responds and president
Trump's response is absolutely vicious
and well deserved totally well deserved
because I'm sorry that sort of
grandstanding is that useful
really is that useful right now like
we're all fairly well aware given the
media reports and what governors are
saying Cuomo is doing a presser on this
every day and being loud it by the media
for it and do you really think that the
federal government is sitting there
going oh well I guess you know I I guess
people just gonna have to die I mean
we're just not gonna try here everyone
is doing their best
everyone is obviously doing their best
the government sucks at things
welcome to the nature of government
welcome to government okay so president
Trump writes back an open letter to
Schumer and you can tell when Trump
writes the letter himself he wrote this
one himself right he had like 1/8 in the
room and he basically dictated in the
person spellcheck Ted here is what Trump
wrote he wrote dear Senator Schumer
thank you for your democrat public
relations letter an incorrect sound
bites which are wrong in every way he
won as you are aware vice president
Pence is in charge of the task force by
almost all accounts he has done a
spectacular job to the defense
production act has been consistently
used by my team and me for the purchase
of billions of dollars worth of
equipment medical supplies ventilators
and other related items it has been
powerful leverage so powerful that
companies generally do whatever we are
asking without even a formal notice they
know something is coming and that's all
they need to know three a senior
military officer is in charge of
purchasing distributing etc his name is
Rear Admiral John Powell wits he is
working 24 hours a day is highly
respected by everyone if you remember my
team gave you this information but for
public relations purposes you chose to
ignore it for we have given New York
many things including hospitals and
medical centers medical supplies record
numbers of ventilators and more you
should have had New York much better
prepared than you did as dr. pouchy and
dr. Brooks said yesterday New York was
very late in its fight against the virus
as you are aware
the federal government is merely a
backup for state governments
unfortunately your state needed far more
of a backup than most others and then
from really gets going says if you spent
less time on your ridiculous impeachment
hoax which went haplessly on forever and
ended up going nowhere except increasing
my poll numbers and instead focusing on
helping the people of New York New York
would not have been so completely
unprepared for the invisible enemy
no wonder ALC and others are thinking
about running against you in the primary
if they did it would likely win
fortunately we have been working with
your state and city governments Governor
Andrew Cuomo and Mayor Bill de Blasio to
get the job done you've been missing in
action except when it comes to the press
while you've stated that you don't like
Andrew Cuomo you want to start working
alongside him for the good of all New
Yorkers I've known you for many years
but I never knew how bad a senator you
are for the state of New York until I
became president if you have any
questions please do not hesitate to call
or in the alternative call Rear Admiral
Powell it's sincerely Donald J Trump so
I have a question is any of this like
that useful right now like that anyway I
will admit that Trump's letter is super
funny and well deserved because Schumer
is in my favorite thing was Schumer's
response to this so Schumer responds to
this I'm appalled appalled president
from sending this very you started it
dude he sent an open letter saying that
the federal response is inadequate and
blah accomplishing nothing except
grandstanding and I say I can't believe
the president wrote me a mean letter oh
oh the Pearl clutching I honestly
honest-to-god just shut up just
ridiculous is any of this doing it like
people are dying 20 million people gonna
lose their jobs by the end of next week
probably you want to shut up about your
little partisan petty feud right now I'm
like you know get crap done you know not
like green initiatives which Chuck
Schumer recommend yesterday by the way
Chuck Schumer is like oh you know we
should do we should we should build
windmills you want these people in
charge of your life seriously like I
understand we need government right now
to do things they're doing it but they
suck at it they're not in getting the
checks out till September they're trying
to shove windmills and and diversity
quotas into two trillion dollar packages
you want these people in charge of your
life when all this is over I keep
hearing that this is a movement we're
getting now America is gonna come out of
this ready for more big government if
you come out of this right for more big
government you have lost your damn mind
you have lost your mind when you come
out of this the first thing you should
be saying is get that government the
hell away from me for as long as
possible and as fast as possible and get
their asses in gear when it comes to
preparing for blacks
and that's their main job yeah but
here's Chuck Schumer pretending to be
very appalled that President Trump being
mean to him after he sent an open letter
calling Trump an incompetent buffoon I
spoke to the president late this
afternoon and explained it and the
result is this letter and so I'm just
appalled you know I say to the president
just stop the pettiness people are dying
and so President Trump we need
leadership we need to get the job done
stop the pettiness let's get it done
let's roll up our sleeves I sent the
letter with the best of intentions
trying to improve a very bad situation
oh oh that was hit with the best of
intentions you sense a public letter a
public letter yeah you know what you
could do pick up the phone you said you
talked to Trump yesterday weird did you
do it by open letter or did you call him
up on the phone you know this device
that we've had for well over a century
at this point you know this device that
you pick up your phone and you talk to
the person and then there's no written
record of it and also you can talk to
the person directly without you know
releasing it to millions of people at
the same time unbelievable unbelievable
okay so one other thing that I hate that
I'd be remiss in not mentioning today so
we were told very early on that this and
and I have abided by the opinion of the
experts all along the way here we've
been told very early on that this was
not in any way develop this is
coronavirus was not developed in any way
by a Chinese laboratory and now now
there's a piece by David Ignatius in the
Washington Post talking about the
possibility that um by the way maybe
this leaked from a Chinese laboratory
whoops whoops David Ignatius can not me
David Ignatius of the Washington Post he
says the story of how the novel
coronavirus emerged in Wuhan China has
produced a nasty propaganda battle
between the US and China the two sides
have traded some of the sharpest charges
made between two nations since the
Soviet Union in 1985 falsely accused the
CIA of manufacturing aids US
intelligence officials don't think the
pandemic was caused by deliberate
wrongdoing the outbreak that has now
swept the world instead began with a
simpler story I'll be at one with tragic
consequences the prime suspect is
natural transmission from bats to humans
perhaps through unsanitary markets but
scientists don't rule out that an
accident at a research laboratory in
Wuhan might have spread a deadly batis
that had been collected
for scientific study okay now I'm old
enough to remember when Tom cotton was
ripped for suggesting that there might
be information that maybe this is what
happened he said I can't confirm this is
what happened I'm not saying I know this
is what happened I'm not saying the data
support this is what happened but there
been some pretty strong rumors coming
out of China this may have been
something that happened a good science
bad safety is how Senator Tom cotton put
his theory in a February 16th tweet he
rang such a breach or natural
transmission as more likely than the two
extreme possibilities an accidental leak
of an engineered bio weapon or a
deliberate release cut-ins earlier loose
talk about bio weapons set off a furor
back when it first raised it in late
January called the outbreak worse than
Chernobyl Trump and Pompeyo added the
buyout to the bio last month describing
the corona virus as the Chinese virus
and the Wu hen virus of course that was
not a problem this was developed I mean
with not developed but obviously allowed
to disseminate by the Chinese government
lied about by the Chinese government
lied to the w-h-o the Chinese government
is solely responsible for this if we're
all going to be forced to wear face
masks by the way like if we all have to
wear face masks I really want to put out
one at Daily wire that just says on the
face mask eff communism because this is
the Communist virus China dished wild
irresponsible allegations of its own
says David Ignatius on March 12th
Chinese foreign ministry spokesperson
Alicia and Xiao charged it might be the
u.s. army who brought the epidemic to
Wuhan he retweeted an article that
claimed that the US troops might have
spread the virus when they attended the
world military Games in Wuhan in October
of 2019 China retreated on March 22nd
when ambassador to the US quí tank I
told Axios that such rumors were crazy
on both sides to be clear US
intelligence officials think there's no
evidence that the corona virus was
created in the laboratory as a potential
bio weapon solid scientific research
shows it wasn't engineered by humor
humans and that it originated in bats
but it is unclear how the outbreak
occurred in the first place what's
increasingly clear is that the initial
origin story that the virus was spread
by people who ate the bats at the
Hawaiian
seafood market in Wuhan is shaky hmm
scientists have now identified the
culprit as a bat coronavirus
through genetic sequencing bats were not
sold at the seafood market although that
market could have sold animals that had
contact with bats
The Lancet noted in the january study
the first kovin 19 case in Wuhan had no
connection to the seafood market at all
there's a competing theory that
scientists have been puzzling about for
weeks as David Ignatius less than 300
yards from the seafood market is the
Wuhan branch of the Chinese Centre for
Disease Control and Prevention
researchers from that facility and the
nearby Wuhan Institute of virology have
posted articles about collecting back
coronaviruses from around China for
study to prevent future illnesses did
one of those samples lead or was
hazardous leaked or was hazardous waste
deposited in a place where it could
spread Richard II bright Rutgers
microbiologist said the first human
infection could have occurred as a
natural accident but he bred caution it
could also have occurred as a lab
accident with an accidental infection of
a laboratory worker
so this anemia tries the the virus but
there was a Chinese study that was
curiously withdrawn in ResearchGate
it was a brief article by hotel Xiao and
li Xiao from gung Chows South China
University of Technology I apologize
from mispronunciations in editions the
origins of natural recombination and
intermediate host the killer corona
virus probably originated from a lab in
Wuhan safety level name needs to be
reinforced in high risk of biohazardous
laboratories so then it is a complete
government failure right then it is not
even the government didn't lock it down
in Wuhan the labs are run by the Chinese
government mu Han there are no private
labs in China as far as I'm aware okay
so that means that it's a communist
country that means this is purely and
simply Chernobyl I didn't mean for it to
happen and it did happen and people were
punished basically publicly for talking
about it pretty well done democracy dies
in darkness Tom cotton is bad for even
mentioning this possibility and oh by
the way it's also maybe the most likely
possibility now since the original
suggestion that somebody just a dab at
at the wool hen market now appears to be
less plausible than the alternative
explanation which is that the apparently
the bad virus was the bat that this came
from was like 600 miles away from Wu hen
and the only way it gets there is
presumably if somebody takes the virus
and brings it to the laboratory there
well done everybody well done already
well we will be back here later today
we'll be taking your questions at eight
five five two three six 32:28 hang in
there
again pay attention to all of the
strictures the administration is right
the scientists are right pay attention
to all the structures right now and also
scientists get your asses in gear give
us some information on what this is
gonna look like six months from now a
year from now you're three months
studies are not sufficient to keep
people locked up for months on end is
just not going to work it's not going to
work if you want us to pay attention to
the structures we have to know what the
rules are going to do and what they are
not
to do and we have to know what the
projection of this virus looks like not
for the next week not for the next two
weeks not for the next month but what
happens when we all leave our houses
because we are not staying in our houses
for a year it's not happening okay we'll
be back here later today or next week
have yourself a safe weekend spend time
with family and try to enjoy yourselves
take a vacation too you know like your
kitchen I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
bench Bureau show the Ben Shapiro show
is produced by Colton Haas directed by
Mike joiner executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling assistant
director Pavel white house key technical
producer Austin Stephens playback and
media operated by Nick Sheehan associate
producer Katie Swinton edited by Adam
Tsai events audio is mixed by Mike core
Amina hair and makeup is by Nika Geneva
the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh show it's not
just another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen
you